welcome calculator fancies to another
numberphile unboxing my name is Matt
Parker and today we're opening the
little professor what account go this is
the only calculator with unboxed so far
which actually is exhibited in the
Science Museum in London not this
particular model but an early little
professor is on display there this one
here you can see it's ages 6 to 11 it's
got the picture of a professor staring
at you and just to really creeped you
out this one here just peeking over the
top for bonus creepiness and on the back
you can see it's got 8,000 problems I
guess that's a quota once you've solved
8,000 problems on this calculator it
just falls apart and there are five
levels of difficulty I guess it ranks
whatever you're doing and gives you a
level of how difficult your calculations
oh and as you can see for a Texas
Instrument calculator it's of course got
every language under the Sun listed out
for all look at all these different
languages that's absolutely amazing and
I mean the reason is that because it's
from Texas Texas is the state in the
u.s. that's most famous for being very
multicultural people all around the
world
openly embraced which is why they have
all these different languages on the
back okay so let's uh let's pop this
open and see what we're going to do I
will of course as always use my handy
scalpel there yeah this is the safest
way to do it to avoid ruining your mint
condition blocks let's get right in
there and then we'll give the cut on the
back oh okay all that opens like that I
mean that works just as well I guess
okay so in here we have a little look at
that this is if he's staring at you
through a frosted bathroom window that's
what you would see if you were to
suddenly appear outside the shower while
you're in there and then in here we have
the little professor instruction booklet
which Oh controversial hinges from the
top first of all here's all the safety
to ensure the complete safety of your
child please do not allow them to access
the instruction manual oh because I mean
there's some dangerous knowledge in here
and it's not safe for young innocent
impressionable minds you don't want your
young child exposed to other languages
so will for safety purposes we'll leave
that for now and then we also get
the warranty oh okay so should should
you not get all eight thousand problems
there is a warranty there okay so let's
get the little professor out okay
someone's already put in eight what
could be plus or divide maybe that's the
problem
guess what the symbol is and then five
so I guess we put an answer in so that
would be at 13 so one three and then oh
oh okay so that I've got a star must be
I've got to write 7 plus 7 that be 14
I've got it right okay okay okay
controversially it seems that as opposed
to me asking the calculator a question
and giving me the answer we're doing
this the other way around for a while so
the calculator here is giving me the
questions that would be a nine and then
I'm giving it the answers which makes me
feel a bit for oh sure that's not
divided so that's plus four well look at
that little party look at it's going off
oh well I do now plus five minus it
seems in little professor asks new the
questions which and all you do is enter
the answer which obviously makes these
calculation buttons on the side here
entire redundant this is the firework
display should you wish to celebrate a
victory or a disclaimer if you wish to
add a disclaimer to any of your answers
you press that and this is the podium so
if you want to go straight to the podium
at the end of the owner is the
difficulty level sorry I'm going up in
steps now we're talking Wow
so what's that 715 plus seven plus one
still I mean obviously there's no
doesn't even carry over any other
columns come on
although I've yeah looky Jackie it has a
little fit 900 ok great for a little fit
look at that ready look at leas freaking
out I mean okay we probably shouldn't
give too many burst of excitement doom
because he's going to pass out I'm also
churning through my 8,000 our problems
and you know I don't want to use them
all up now I want to save some for
future generations so there you are the
little professor the calculator that
asks you the problems this is an A
calculators like an inverse calculator
so it does the opposite of Calcutta in
fact if you get a normal calculator and
you collide it with this anti calculator
fast enough
they annihilate and emit a photon scores
for the little professor Solar anti
calculator
the display is a six it's quite readable
functionality zero because you can't do
any calculations on it accuracy five
organ Amma kicks cred negative seven
you will lose cred using this in a math
department and durability
I'm going to give durability a seven it
survived that crash quite well that's a
grand total of 17 and an average score
of 2.8 3 reoccurring thank you to
Squarespace for its support of
numberphile Squarespace is a fantastic
service for anyone wanting to start
their own website blog podcast online
shop you name it I use it myself and
can't recommend it highly enough if
you're a total beginner the Squarespace
interface makes everything super easy
yet you still end up with a really
professional beautiful website that'll
look good on any computer or on a mobile
phone if you're a bit more advanced and
I know a lot of numberphile viewers are
there are loads of options to dig deeper
into the code and really personalize
your site they have something for
everyone don't just take my word for it
you can easily create your own site with
no charge
no credit card required just do it see
what you think if you decide it is for
you like I did then use the offer code
numberphile when signing up and you'll
get 10% off at checkout squarespace.com
slash numberphile and thank you to them
for supporting our videos